[Music]
Uh hello everyone. Thank you so much for
being here for uh sticking around for
this talk. Um I'm going to be talking
about optimizing inference for voice
models in production. I'm going to be
talking mostly about the runtime
component but also just a little bit on
the infrastructure side. Um just a quick
introduction. Um I'm Philip from B 10.
Base 10 is a model inference platform.
Uh we run production workloads for a
wide variety of AI native startups and
enterprises. Um I'm based in here in SF.
Um I actually just moved here. It's
really awesome. My favorite part about
being in SF is much better sports teams
than I had in Chicago. Um and uh one of
my favorite voice models is Orpheus TTS.
Um which we're going to be talking about
a whole bunch today. Um quick agenda. So
we're going to talk about TTS model
architecture like what is a text to
speech model actually when you look on
the config in hugging face. Uh what sort
of performance metrics are we looking
at? What sort of optimization techniques
can we do to make the model better? Um
how do we measure whether or not we
succeeded? And then finally, what can we
do on the infrastructure and client code
to not shoot ourselves in the foot after
doing a ton of runtime work and then
just adding all that latency back by not
doing our client code correctly.
So architecture,
this is one of the things I've been
learning this year which has been pretty
great uh to to realize it's made life a
lot simpler at the runtime level. Now
this is wrong like the the the thing up
here uh that that I'm going to say is
that like everything is an LLM. uh that
is that is wrong but it's useful. Um
there's kind of like two types of
models. There's autogressive
transformers models that are LLM or very
LLM adjacent. Um you see this in
embeddings. You see this in
transcription with stuff like whisper
TTS um is another example. You also have
the more like diffuser image type
models. Um which is like a very
different optimization problem. But
something that's cool is because TTS
models are so architecturally similar to
LLMs or in many cases derived directly
from LLMs, we can access the rich
ecosystem of LLM tooling and use it to
make TTS models better. So the TTS model
that we're going to be using and as an
example all day um is Orpheus TTS. We're
using it for two reasons. Okay, three
reasons. The two reasons are because
it's open source and it's really good.
And also I think uh Elias and Amu and
everyone at Canopy Labs is really
awesome. So uh that's the that's the
third reason we're we're talking about
their model. But it's a Llama 3.2 3B
backbone. So like if you look at this is
the little like config from hugging face
copy and pasted onto the screen. It's a
llama for causal LM architecture. And so
because of that we can do like all of
our normal llama stuff to this model and
make it faster. Um they did a couple
things. I mean they did a bunch of
things to make it work but a couple
things that are relevant here. There is
a larger vocab size because you need all
the speech specific tokens like laugh
and stuff. Um and then they also
extended the context length for thrope
scaling. So we got to make sure
everything we do supports that. So
performance metrics like what do we want
to actually do here? Uh we we think
about LLM metrics um a little bit here.
Uh we we just look at them a little bit
differently. So in LLMs you talk about
time to first token. Now we're talking
about time to first bite or sometimes
even time to first sentence. Uh we we
need a little bit more of a useful
output um from the model before we
really start feeling good about our
response time. We do think about tokens
per second although we're going to think
about it differently which I'll explain
later. And we mostly think about
throughput which is you know how many
requests are we able to serve at a given
time.
So on that, you know, goals perspective,
if you ask me like, "Hey, Philip, how do
you want to optimize llama in general?"
I'll like I'll say, "Well, we want a lot
of TPS. We want hundred. We want 500
TPS. We want a thousand tokens per
second. We want as many tokens per
second as we can get." With voice
models, you actually don't necessarily
need that. In many cases, you only want
as many tokens per second as you need
for a real-time stream. for Orpheus
that's like 83 tokens per second which
for like a three billion parameter LLM
is nothing. Um but what we actually want
to do instead is we want to once we hit
that mark start optimizing for time to
first bite so that our latency is really
good and start optimizing for
concurrency so that we can get more
connections and spend less on GPUs.
So our goal in general if all of these
very nice and definitely not AI
generated people are all the different
like voices that our that our model is
capable of creating these are all the
voice agents that we're running. How can
we make all of these people fit on one
or even less than one GPU? That's the
goal. So how do we do it?
Bunch of ways. Um so first off it's an
LLM. Um, if you are running an LLM with
like VLM for example, um, you can
generally in many cases get better
performance with Tensor Rotlm. Uh,
Tensor Rot is something that we've been
using at Base 10 a lot. I like to joke
that I'm the unofficial marketing
department for Tensor RT LLM because of
how much I talk about it. Uh, but it
really is fast. It can be a little bit
complicated from a developer experience
perspective to get up and running with
it, but once you are up and running, um,
it it works really well. Uh, we can also
just like quantize the model. Um, even
though it's small, you can always make
it faster by making it smaller. Uh, with
Hopper architecture, we quantize this
model to FP8 pretty successfully. I know
usually quantizing really small models
like this can lead to performance
degragation, but for this model, it's
working pretty well in FP8, even when we
quantize the KV cache. And then a lot of
the other runtime stuff is actually more
like audio specific than it is LLM
specific. So, one of the big challenges
that we don't have with LLMs, which are
just parsing nice, convenient bits of
text back and forth, is you have your
audio, you have your audio codec, you
have your decoding, all that kind of
stuff. So, we use snack, which I was
very disappointed to learn is not an
actual tasty snack, um, but an audio
decoder. And we actually use torch
compile, um, and torch compile you might
be used to running on, you know, a a
model u compiling your model weights to
make your runtime faster. We're actually
using the same kind of system with torch
compile and with um PyTorch inference
mode on the audio decoder and running
that on the GPU. Um we make sure that
all the token batching um token level
batching works well throughout the
entire pipeline and support multiple
streaming protocols. Um yeah, so these
are the engine settings that you would
need. um you've got the you know
quantization type of FP8 KV the FP8
context uh FMHA um in order to you know
support the uh support the um hopper
architecture and the
uh quantization there. Um and here's a
quick code sample of I got a little
ahead of my slides I guess. Here's a
little quick code sample of the audio
decoding. Um so we are basically you
know batching. Um usually we would talk
about continuous batching when we're
talking about LLM optimization. We want
to package all those tokens together. In
this case we are doing dynamic batching.
Um so we're trying to pack as much into
a batch as we can but every 15
milliseconds we're going to uh shoot it
out. Um you've got that timeout setup
here. Um if you want to trade off um for
a little bit of latency for more
throughput you can make that batch
bigger. Um, so yeah, we don't have token
level continuous batching yet here, but
we do have dynamic batching, which is
going to get you pretty close. Um, and
because of this, actually something
that's that I was surprised about uh
when we profiled this is that our TTS
imple implementation with Orpheus is
actually in many cases CPUbound, which
is kind of where you want to be. Um, you
can throw more CPUs at a resource uh
pretty pretty efficiently. Um even
though the next token production and the
audio co decoding are both on the GPU um
both of those loops hit the CPU at
different points um and that can
actually be the bottleneck in the number
of simultaneous streams that we're able
to create.
So how do we do like I just showed you a
lot of code and talked through it really
quickly without really getting into
depth. Uh that could all just be smoke
and mirrors. Uh let's see let's see if
it's actually any faster. Um, so again,
the number one thing is going to be
simultaneous streams because you want to
be able to be very costefficient and use
fewer GPU resources to serve a, you
know, large amount of traffic. And in
this case, our base implementation, I
don't necessarily want to like call
anyone out because there's a lot of
really good ways to run this model. Um,
you can get really good performance with
VLM. Um but this is just kind of like
the offtheshelf um just take it run it
completely standard uh implementation.
So with variable traffic we're able to
support 16 simultaneous streams and with
constant traffic 24 simultaneous streams
on um an H100 MIG. So this is actually
half an H100 GPU. It's a skew that we do
a lot because it's really good for these
small models where you want the Hopper
performance, the Hopper architecture
uplift in Tensor RTLM, the FP8 support,
but you don't want to pay for like an
entire 80 gigabyte GPU for just a 3
billion parameter model. So, you know,
we're seeing much better um much much
better concurrency. So, if you kind of
like price that out with like our list
prices and stuff, um, you can get, you
know, a few cents per hour of of
conversation, um, which is going to be,
you know, substantially better than if
you're if you have the volume for it.
It's going to be substantially better
than paying for a sort of like pertoken
type API.
But, okay, sure, maybe it's cheap at
scale, but is it fast? Yes, it's fast.
Um so with the you know with the tot
implementation on the MIGs and on the
H100s we can actually get all the way
down to 150 millisecond time to first
bite um in like real world uh testing
that we've done. Now that we'll we'll
talk in a minute like that doesn't mean
your whole pipeline is that fast. That's
just like one part of the pipeline. Uh
but it's it's important because you know
you definitely don't want to be spending
a lot of time waiting around for that
first token.
So
to kind of transition into that that
discussion of like what can go wrong
here like you have this graph and you
have this you know nice uh config that I
had up here and you're like all right
cool I'm going to take this I'm going to
put it in production and I'm going to
see the results that uh that he put up
on screen and it's going to work great
and the answer is no it's not it's a
little bit harder than that. Um, so the
thing is like non-runtime factors when
we get especially with these small
models and with these multimodal systems
can actually be like way more important
than your runtime. Um, and that's your
lat your infrastructure and your client
code because you know I I showed here
all right maybe maybe I got it you know
I I cut the runtime in in half um from
from the base implementation I I saved a
couple hundred milliseconds very easy to
add those couple hundred milliseconds
back and well beyond that by you know
sending my query to New York instead of
California or by having to establish a
session every time I uh you know run my
client code. Um, so a few like pitfalls
to avoid. Um, number one, like if you go
in, you know, our our model library or
something and we're just trying to get
you started very quickly um with this
with this kind of inference sample. Um,
it's basically going to be, hey, use
requests, make a stream, stream it to
your local computer and start, you know,
playing it on ffmpeg or something. The
issue is that here like the requests are
going to be sent sequentially and you
need to create a new session every time.
um that takes time. So if you're using
this in production, you want a code
sample. By the way, this is all up on
our GitHub. Um you'll want a code sample
that looks a lot more like a
benchmarking script where you're using a
um multipprocess pool. um you're sharing
the you're sharing the session between
all of these different requests and
you're actually sending traffic with the
concurrency that allows you to, you
know, saturate this benchmark with, you
know, the the multiple concurrent
requests.
Finally, both of these code samples,
they do sit on top of HTTP and HTTP
streaming. Um, in many cases, if you're
implementing voice pipelines, you're
going to use something like LiveKit or
Pipecat or something. And you're also
potentially going to be using a
different protocol. You're going to be
using something like websockets or gRPC,
which we do have support for. Um, and
finally, I wanted to leave you on the
thought that these uh, you know, these
models are only one part of a voice
agent pipeline. So like we can spend a
lot more than 15 minutes actually
talking about like the very detailed uh
implementation mechanics of making your
voice model faster of you know we we
haven't even touched on stuff like
fine-tuning the model um you know custom
voices zeroot voice cloning um being
able to you know remove static and
popping at the end of messages there's
there's there's a lot of work to do just
on the voice part but it really only is
onethird of the problem when I think
about voice agents. I think about three
parts, listening, thinking, talking. Um,
and the most important thing here is
again, while you can have great run
times, the infrastructure to connect
these three together is really what's
going to determine your latency. Being
able to go from one model to have the
next one running in the same data center
with, you know, minimal like minimal
network overhead in between the two. uh
even things as simple as not having to
go off and do a hair pin um at the DNS
level and come back. If that saves you
10 milliseconds on every step and your
voice pipeline has this and you know a
chunking algorithm, it's got an
interruption model and so you end up
having four or five steps. Well, there
just hair pinning alone is costing you
40 or 50 milliseconds and that can be
10% of your SLA for for a voice model.
So yeah, uh that's that's my that's my
main point here is that as much fun as
it is to talk about the runtime stuff
and as much work as we do there, the the
infrastructure and the client
implementation is equally important if
not more so. Anyway, thank uh so yeah,
that's the that's the review. Um thank
you all for coming through. Uh I have uh
we're doing an event next week at uh
Fogo to Chiao which is going to be
pretty fun. I'm going to be talking in
more detail about building some uh
systems with open source models and
there's also going to be a lot of stake.
So definitely come on through uh if
you're interested and um I'm on I'm on
Twitter, I'm on LinkedIn, so it's base
10. Um hit me up if you have any
questions about this or anything else
model performance. Thank you so much and
I'll let you go 8 seconds early.
[Music]